the Academy is always careful to utilize  the outstanding talents in each field to  present the various awards for the  finest achievements in costume design  here are Wendell quarry and Ernie Kovacs  wearing their own original creations  you read the nominations I'll describe  the girls all right  first the costume from Bell book and  candle designed by job the weak girl is  Victoria Shaw  she's not stray lien blonde costumes for  The Buccaneer  we're designed by Ralph jester Edith Ted  and Jon Jensen  the girl is Inger Stevens  she's a Swedish blind by Charles lemare  and Mary wills the girl is Christine  career she's a French blonde this  costume from some came running was  designed by Walter Plunkett  the girl is johanna more this costume is  from gigi designed by cecil beaton  the girl is Jayne Mansfield  he's a girl like he said  and now for the envelope go back set it  GG Cecil Beaton  mr. Cecil Beaton mr. Arthur freed  a big British aloe from cecil beaton  thank you